il ya 50 ans donc un homme seul à
refuser la capitulation
il a fait de londres où il venait de
s'exiler comment pourquoi charles de
gaulle at il agi ainsi rappel historique
laurent boussier 18 juin 40 le soleil
brille sur londres où l'événement
principal de la journée sera le discours
de churchill devant le parlement
sujet d'inquiétude pour les anglais le
sort de la flotte française après la
demande d'armistice du gouvernement de
bordeaux la veille un général français
le général de gaulle sous secrétaire
d'état à la défense dans le gouvernement
de paul reynaud est arrivé dans la
capitale britannique
il est seul il n'a ni troupes une
structure politique ni force économique
il possède en tout et pour tout une
somme de 100 mille francs que lui a
remise paul reynaud est la clé d'un
petit appartement à ces mots le plein
dans le centre de londres
dès son arrivée il a rencontré churchill
et lui a demandé de pouvoir utiliser la
bbc pour lancer un appel aux français
dans la matinée charles de gaulle a
rédigé le texte de son appel il la
rature et recommencer chaque mot est
important
elisabeth de méribel une amie de l'aide
de camp du général fera office de
secrétaire la fin du test n'a été dicté
par geoffrey de caussels robe non
accompagnés jal de vol qu'il faisait des
démarches à l'aude dans la matinée
jusqu'au début de l'après midi parce que
j'avais pas ici a lieu jusqu'au bout
prête à l'esprit était le général de
gaulle était tendu
le même faisait passer un rocher de la
taupe tech directon très grands traits
impression c'est en costume avec des
leggings et je l'avais montré
extrêmement de colle
c'est à partir de 15h sur cette machine
avec deux doigts qui est après le fameux
appel vers 18 heures le général et son
aide de camp geoffroy de courcel quitte
ses mots plaisent et se fait conduire en
taxi à la bbc charles de gaulle est en
uniforme avec quelques feuilles de chêne
blanc blanc à la main à son arrivée le
directeur de la radio anglaise l'accueil
et l'accompagnement quatrième étage dans
le studio b 2 le général ça soit
silencieusement auprès du speaker des
émissions françaises qui lui passe la
parole à la fin de son bulletin
d'information
moi général de gaulle
j'entreprends il fuit en angleterre
cette tâche nationale
j'invite tous les militaires français
des armées de terre de mer et de l'air
invite ses ingénieurs
l'appel du 18 juin n'a pas été
enregistré les techniciens de la vie
s'il était trop occupé par la
préparation du discours de churchill en
france peu de personnes entend dire il
apparut comme une péripétie de cette fin
du mois de juin et pour de gaulle
l'essentiel n'était pas là il avait dit
à haute voix qu'il existait une autre
politique que celle de péta une autre
politique que celle de l'armistice